[Applaudissements]
elle a absolument changé ma vie
juste après son histoire, donnez-moi juste le
courage de savoir que je peux faire n'importe quoi
ce qu'il a dit, il a truqué le père pudiera, le
capitaine Switzer Jean Estes était au diesel
[Musique] Le
boxeur cubain Damien sur Tenma Ivana maja
todo esto  la lluvia Santa set American
associate is a juice box in inna llaha
la femme à voir official manpuku summer
Otto a choisi Allah s'ouvre elle pourrait se
transformer en un homme vous savez qu'elle pourrait avoir de
grandes jambes ou pousser des poils sur sa poitrine ou
son utérus allait  tomber ou
quelque chose de terrible c'étaient les
mythes dominants et les gens les croyaient
mais les femmes elles-mêmes les croyaient
et c'était une partie effrayante dit figure
Coronel un couguar malade Miller schématique
d'un long train ma se ma Popovic Oso pas
un non je ne veux pas  une chose, il a juste
explosé de rage et il a dit qu'aucune Dame n'avait
jamais couru de marathon et il
croyait que c'était impossible pour les femmes, il a
dit que les femmes étaient trop faibles et trop
fragiles et je me suis mis en colère et j'ai dit que je sais que
je  peut le faire
si réformé une description un coq chanter
Switzer laisser Lisa no N
Missa cornichon Camilla Camilla prix lapa
- Camilla co-directeur démérite vieux jock
Semple à travers l'est des États-Unis par opposition à
cela, il avait ce visage en colère vraiment féroce
et il a crié à moi obtenir  l'
enfer de ma course et donnez-moi ces chiffres
et il m'a jeté en arrière comme ça et a essayé
de retirer mes dossards sur le devant et j'ai
sauté en arrière j'ai dit hein tu sais qu'il avait
tellement peur
sonna rencontrer kirk est soudé barre de
joint d'étanchéité  le réalisateur plonge sur le poteau la
photo Foley vers la course à pied la plus célèbre du monde de la moisissure
attire même quelques longues jambes
Lady Catherine Switzer Ellis Ave à V
savoir / lachemann ou pouce Je n'étais pas au
marathon de Boston pour prouver quoi que ce soit
c'est le moment où tout a changé dans
ma vie et  J'ai transformé mon entraîneur, j'ai dit que
je finirais cette course sur mes mains et
mes genoux s'il le fallait parce que je ne
termine pas cette course, personne ne va
croire que les femmes peuvent faire ça qu'elles
méritent d'être ici sockos no se  e pattes
sont Attila lady plumie sur Sean Ellis
makovan American Bastogne puis clairement
fam Ausmus on deuce
Je suis sukhsayar George V au
marathon de boston l'année dernière 46% du champ était des
femmes et ce pourcentage augmente
qui ne pourrait certainement pas exister sans les
femmes de  occlusion le cosmétique même L
tu me manques gamin sur son analyste était là-dessus
en ville les cuisiniers en bas à Cavell ont
enlevé vous avez des images de film de cela
et vous avez le parrainage de cela et vous
apportez cela au CIO cela attire l'attention
bien c'est ça que
vous voyez utiliser  mais Alphaville directement
ferme saoudienne Omaha Toledo Katherine
Katherine Katherine Switzer organiser un
chat avec des cuisiniers vers le bas ensemble de ventilation P
Fresnel cookie blue famille dominante moi
Bruce Kulick Lucio lock sauf toi Mina
un dev nouveau synonyme le plus Sebastian
quelqu'un est si pauvre qu'il n'a pas de chaussures
et vous leur donnez un t-shirt et un métal
et vous leur dites que vous êtes quelqu'un que vous
venez de courir 5k ou 10k ils sont quelqu'un et
ils font ce changement
Événements à Ubud Ankita mad l co  mplex sur ou
Tenma pour qu'ils vivent Je me sens mieux
maintenant que lorsque j'ai commencé
c'est un très bon signe c'est
une expérience tellement inspirante non seulement de l'
entendre parler mais de pouvoir courir avec elle
Kathrine Switzer a continué les
doses de groupe SPD Eriksson sont sans peur  contre Arkansas
commune moi qui fait une réforme de la danse en deux temps
em que nous ils ils
coupent les cuisiniers paul brizzi Liz Alma la plupart des femmes dans
le monde vivent encore dans une situation effrayante la
plupart des femmes et cette femme
pourrait être sûre en Afrique du Nord ou en
Afghanistan ou en  La Somalie ou tout ce
qu'elle pourrait vivre à côté de vous et les
femmes partout où elle a besoin d'une
situation d'autonomisation
[Musique]